welcome to Table Talk where each week I
impact insights from Christian theology
and spirituality that help you become
more thoughtful calm and happier human
being my name is Brett and today I want
to get into part three of our series on
handling relational conflict so in our
previous episode we looked into the
concept of bumping into myself the idea
being that sometimes a disagreement is
just a disagreement but when I begin to
feel very strong almost overwhelming
negative emotions not evil emotions
right this isn't about labeling emotions
bad emotions are just emotions
it's simply nate- motions just means you
know ones that don't feel good anger
bitterness hurt offense things like that
that it's helpful to realize that while
the person I'm in conflict with they may
in fact be wrong but still my feelings
are still mine to own right they're
still in a sense my responsibility again
this isn't about blaming myself or
shaming I'm not saying that I'm just
saying that we can't we can't point the
finger at others and say I'm feeling
this way because of you like in the end
we have to realize I'm bumping into
myself right I want to say it's them
it's their fault I'm bumping into them
but actually I'm bumping into me some of
the realizations we had from that was
that often the issue is not the issue
which is what I'm titling this episode
because I believe this is worth
unpacking in a lot more detail so here
are three reasons why what we think the
conflict is about the issue is often not
what the conflict is about number one
because high-intensity conflict is
usually about feeling unloved or unsaved
so feeling unloved or unsafe or what
some psychologists call primary
oceans in other words you have primary
emotions and then you have secondary
emotions for example I might feel Envy
toward someone but really the reason I
feel that is because I don't feel great
about myself right I'm insecure which
comes back to not really believing that
I'm loved or let's say my kid walks down
the street in a car whisks by it almost
runs them over and I freaked out on them
but that's a secondary emotion right
anger is secondary what's primary fear I
feel myself or someone I love is unsafe
right I was afraid I might lose them
forever and so I freaked out so last
week that we brought up the story of
Miriam and Aaron who were the sidekicks
and co-leaders of Moses and the Bible
they also happen to be related to him
which by the way probably didn't make
all this any easier so you'll recall
that in numbers chapter 12 Miriam and
Aaron began to talk to one another and
to others behind Moses his back of
course it was all under the guise that
they just had some concerns about Moses
marriage he had married a foreigner but
then in the next verse it's not about
that stuff at all now they say well
actually it's about you know who God
speaks to and Moses acts like it's just
all about him and doesn't you realize
that God speaks to us and through us as
well can you see how this is turning
into a long list of complaints by the
way that is a sure sign that the issue
is not the issue all right so what is
the real issue well I suspect this
second complaint was probably closer to
the truth what are Aaron and Miriam
feeling sounds like some insecurity is
coming out which is to say they are
feeling underappreciated by Moses which
is in turn to say they feel unloved and
unvalued and this is exactly what
happens to us we have a big list of
complaints we have a file folder of
grievances we have a hundred different
issues but we don't really have 100
different issues do we you probably just
feel either unloved or unsafe or maybe
both right okay so that's the first
reason the issue is often not the issue
second reason issues not the issue is
because it's less about the ingredients
and more about the heat of the oven well
I'll call it the emotional oven notice
that when you are well rested calm at
peace you're all Zen things just roll
off your back like you don't have fights
you don't have arguments you have
discussions you have sane disagreements
but when the pressures on and the stress
levels begin to rise now all the sudden
everything is problematic everything is
the end of the world which is why I say
it's less about the ingredients and more
about the emotional oven what do I mean
by by the ingredients in by ingredients
I mean those little comments those small
actions that slowly throughout the days
or the months or the years of a
relationship they all sort of come
together but as long as your emotional
temperature is turned to cool or at
least very low heat
never really have a chance to make but
all of a sudden the temperature begins
to rise and before you know it your
conflict casserole
I like this metaphor is bubbling in
summary it just might catch on fire no
what's the lesson there well what we
have to ask is this like why this why
now what why am i feeling all this now
why today how did I sleep last night
what what other stresses do I have in my
life did I come into the office in a
huff and get into a conflict with my
coworker because I'm actually hacked off
at my spouse can you see how again often
the issue is not the issue quick
footnote on this this is why I believe
that spiritual practices like silence
prayer journaling etc are incredibly
helpful because they train you to turn
the temperature in your life down
because if your oven is always turned up
to 500° guess what it doesn't matter
what happens you're going to feel like
you're in chronic conflict because it's
less about the ingredients than the heat
of the oven but if you've learned to
keep that temperature low well you can
handle almost anything someone says or
does third reason the issues on the
issue is because I'm probably avoiding
the harder conversation any time you
find yourself locked in chronic conflict
with someone
rest assured whatever you're arguing
about is not the actual issue and often
truth be told it's because your cue
scared to talk about the real issue for
example the wife and husband
some late and they get berated by their
spouse night after night for being out
late yet again and this continues and I
after night after night but but there's
a certain intensity to all of this and
it never gets resolved because the real
issue is not being addressed right
chronic and nag you which is not just a
female thing by the way that's a
stereotype like men and women can nag
right chronic Maggie that's a sign that
the issue is not the issue it's a sign
I'm not really getting I'm not having
the harder conversation someone is not
being honest because if they were honest
what they would say would be something
like this
honey I don't trust that what you say
you're doing when you're out late is
actually what you are doing right that's
the real issue that that's the real
conversation but so often we avoid the
hard conversation the real conversation
and instead we engage in this chronic
back-and-forth tit-for-tat arguments
that just go on and on and on forever
but it's a sigh we're avoiding the real
issue quick pro tip for the really big
conflicts where you like you fear a
confrontation could become worse maybe
just incredibly emotional volatile or
emotionally volatile at the brettly's
just unproductive like you're like this
not to go anywhere um consider having
someone else there uh mutually
agreed-upon third party can make a world
of difference this is especially true if
you have reason to fear for your safety
yeah if that's your situation you need
to have someone else there okay so to
recap why is the issue often not the
issue number one because it's actually
that I feel unloved or unsafe number two
because it's less about the ingredients
and it is about the
the emotional oven number three because
I'm probably avoiding the harder
conversation well that is all for today
if you enjoyed this content please put
the like button or subscribe or comment
below and of course if you found this
helpful and you know someone that you
think also might find it helpful feel
free to share it with them alright love
you lots
grace and peace